ya wanna tell you about sleeping on the
job oh my god did you see that what the
como no Twiggy takaki I see it every
time I close my eyes now okay i'm
reviewing this game and I think he's
going to send his ninjas to kill me
collar hickey cocky is not gonna kill
you oh no I bought I mean he might like
to chop off a limb how'd you write that
game like a six yeah you're dead man
color
okay so ninja gaiden two right it's a
released on the xbox 360 from Microsoft
developed by tecmo in Japan now
Microsoft doesn't have a lot of Japanese
exclusives and so they're trying to make
a big deal out of this one now in some
ways that's a really good thing ninja
gaiden two has amazing ninja combat
you're going to be slicing the heads off
of enemy ninjas and crazy werewolves and
demons from underground and pretty much
of it has a head your mission is to cut
it off and it's a whole lot of fun so
why isn't it you know a great game well
because it's designers concentrated on
that combat to the exclusion of
everything else that makes a third
person action game fun but before we get
into that let's go back to the combat
why is it so good part of it is that
these guys have really refined the form
making it satisfying and fun it's shop
up your enemies but it's also because
ninja gaiden two emphasizes strategy and
awareness of your surroundings it take
all of those limbs that our ninja here
is chopping off these guys now a
limbless ninja believe it or not is a
deadly ninja why because he knows he's
going to die and he is going to take you
with him by suicide bombing you if you
get too close to him so you've got to be
constantly on the lookout for half
ninjas crawling towards you with their
one last good arm now it's stuff like
that that makes ninja guidance combat
really interesting and difficult this is
a very hard game by design it's aimed
right at a small sliver of obsessive
players now there is an easy difficulty
setting which you should by all means
start with if you're not a seasoned pro
but even the easy setting can be a real
jerk sometimes no difficult doesn't mean
bad so what's the problem the problem is
that combat alone does not a polished
game make action games like God of War
have really raised the bar on what we're
supposed to expect from a big-budget
first party microsoft released now first
of all ninja gaiden player-controlled
cam
is just bad it always seems to be in the
wrong place you can't see what's going
on it's tough to adjust it and a lot of
your super awesome ninja moves generally
make you fly back and forth on the
screen and then ruin the camera angle
putting the enemies off-screen so you
can't see them coming to attack you and
and really ninja gaiden two isn't a
free-roaming adventure it's a linear
game it's point A to point B why do I
have to babysit the camera there's only
one place the camera ever needs to be at
any time and the game designer should
put it there not me by leaving the
player in charge the game designer mrs.
all the opportunities where he could be
showing us a bunch of expensive vista's
or dramatic camera angles for fighting
then again ninja gaiden two doesn't
really have any expansive vistas that
would be right for dramatic reveals its
level designs or mostly just big empty
featureless corridors with nothing
interesting to look at and the story
that's not even worth mentioning insofar
as it flip flops between silly and
offensively dumb especially if you feel
the video game should have ditched the
ridiculous outmoded female caricature is
in 1993 and then there's this one boss
battle that's just it's it's just well
let me let me show you where's he going
ok now this boss battle pits you against
an enemy that so many ninjas had to
fight in feudal Japan a triceratops that
is on fire and so basically during this
boss battle it's enough of a pain in the
ass to hit this thing in the head enough
times until it dies but then after you
get its life bar all the way down it
explodes and it kills you instantly wow
that's great game over go all the way
back to the beginning of the boss fight
so now you get back to that point where
he's about to explode you think ok what
do I have to do do I have to run away
from the tricera-cops so I'm out of the
black strange nope
do I ask you you have to shoot the
Triceratops with an arrow so far away
from it when it finally dies at don't
work neither do i have to hold my hands
up in front of my face to shield my face
from a nuclear explosion yeah that's
what you have to do okay this ridiculous
first of all but that's not even the
point the point is that it doesn't it's
not even a matter of taste anymore now I
forgot to go back and do the same lame
boss fight four different times even if
I'm playing perfectly and that's that's
that's just bad game design okay so
let's recap ninja gaiden two has
fantastic combat and for a you know a
significant group of people that's going
to be more than enough but for the
average fan of third person action games
you know the genre has just evolved so
much in the past five years the team
ninja well they seem like they're kind
of stuck in 2002 where a bad camera and
kind of ugly presentation were okay
because we didn't know any better but
now we do and because of that ninja
gaiden two just does not measure up to
more recent innovations in the genre
that's why I'm giving it a six out of
ten
you